the first thing you have to do is you've
got to keep two things in your mind
equally with equal vigor one of them is
you want to keep the fans happy from the
first the first movie that you're making
the sequel of and so you have to
continue the most exciting elements of
the story and the characters and decide
when to jump in the other thing you got
to do is deliver surprise and
originality so you have to figure out
what's gonna be different about the
story what's going to offer the fans
food-for-thought the chimpanzee
character Caesar is so important to the
storyline and yet what people do see on
on screen is computer-generated how has
technology influenced the stories that
ultimately you're able to - right well
it's fascinating because when we came up
with the idea for rise many years ago
the technology to do the film with
computer-generated images didn't exist
but we didn't know that I mean we were
you know we're not techies and so we
just assumed that whatever we wrote
people could figure out a way to
translate that under the screen and then
and then the first film was in
development for I have three years or so
before avatar was made and so it's
really Jim Cameron and and whether who
who's technological you know advances
and in work gave us the opportunity to
do Zeus rise the way we wanted to
because we knew that you know we had to
move beyond actors and makeup and rubber
suits and certainly couldn't use live
chimps because that would you know be
almost a impossible but more importantly
it would be against the theme of what we
were trying to say with rise I would say
though that what's most important in all
of it is that it's really not motion
capture is
as is performance capture because when
you see the eight it really is the
actors performance captured on film and
translated rendered into into aids and
we on both movies seen many many
iterations of what the movie would look
like while the actors were still in
great leotards and in and you forget it
after a while because you just you know
you get to know those characters and the
scenes and what's playing in the scenes
and what's not playing in the scenes and
and different things the actors are
trying and different things that Matt
Reeves is trying as a director and then
it just when these then see it rendered
it really is the performance and Amanda
Rick mentioned James Cameron obviously
you guys have worked with James Cameron
have been working with him on the future
of the Avatar franchise he's somebody
who has said he feeds off the creativity
of others how would you describe his
approach to screenwriting Jim is
extraordinarily generous with his ideas
which are you know he's very inspiring
but he's also incredibly collaborative
so it's there's a lot of yes and you
know when you batting around ideas and
the ideas are good and catching you know
you take them to their farthest
expression you try them out and and you
know he's a wonderful leader and teacher
I mean the learning curve has been very
steep and we've been fortunate before to
work with great directors and this
experience has been particularly special
and kind of thrilling and Rick how would
you describe the the experience of
working with Jim Cameron to the time you
guys have spent with Steven Spielberg
obviously part of the work you guys have
done towards the upcoming Jurassic world
film right well you know it's it's
similar and that both men it's you know
you kind of know very quickly why
they're both
sidered geniuses and so successful in
what they do so that's very similar
they're both extremely nice I mean it
you know it's kind of a strange word to
use for but it they're both really nice
human beings and open again both very
open with their ideas and interested in
your ideas and so you know it's
interesting because you if from afar you
know you think oh my gosh is it would be
nerve wracking but to sit in a room with
someone who's at that level but it's not
that way at all maybe both men really
directors really have put us at ease and
I believe put everybody at ease and and
so so that's all been very very good and
and again you know it's amazing the
ideas that come flying at us was brain